Please welcome Ryan Kiera Armstrong.
(audience applauds)
I'm so happy to meet you.
I'm so happy.
Oh my goodness,
I'm not able to keep it together.
I'm so happy to meet you.
Me either.
I watched the film and it's so good, you're so good in it.
Oh my god, thank you. (cries)
I just... (cries)
It's like, so surreal.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
It's so good, you're so amazing in it.
What have you got in your hands?
So I have
this drawing for you
because how amazing you are and here it is.
Oh my God.
(audience exclaims)
So since there's so many close-ups of eyes
throughout both of the Fire Starters
or two Fire Starters, there's so many closeups
so I figured I would draw one for you
and I clearly, we all equal awesomeness, so.
(audience applauds)
I mean, full-blown framer on wall forever
in nearest spot that I look at every day of my life.
Please sit down.
Is it true that you did something for school in ET?
Am I getting this right?
So yes, right before I was actually ever an actor,
I was, I think I was like six, seven years old
and it was dress up as your inspiration day,
like dress up as whoever inspires you
and so I ended up dressing up
as you when you were in ET
and so now that I'm here, it's insane and this is crazy.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
It's so cool.
But then I got to do Firestarter and it changed,
one is like, love everybody
and the other is, I will blow you up...
Oh yes, oh yes.
If you mess with me and my family.
It was probably the most empowering thing
that ever could have happened to me.
What was the experience like for you?
'Cause it really changed my personality.
Oh yes, I also, I love like.... beforehand, I like...
Okay sorry, I just cannot speak right now.
So I also love the fact like she has superpowers, right?
So she's this character with superpowers
and I go to the movie theaters,
I've watched superpower movies all the time.
So this is crazy, first of all
and then when I'm on set, I just feel like
this empowerment of like,
back away or this this will all happen to you
and so it was honestly so cool
and I love seeing the effects as well,
'cause I got to see all the stunts, it was so cool.
There are not a lot of us young girls out there
who have the superpowers and I don't know why that's not
a more tapped into market.
I would love to see young girls kicking butt.
Honestly, yes.
I agree.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, let's go.
But I'm so glad that we're so lucky
that these moments or opportunities
have been reserved for these incredible fortunes
that we've gotten to learn about ourselves,
work hard and bring out characters
and films that speak to people 'cause they are unique.
They are definitely unique.
Oh my God,
it's just so crazy.
It is crazy.
(audience claps)
Will you come here with me?
Oh sorry.
Oh God, stuck on skirt.
I was seven then, I'm 47 now.
Can you believe that?
That was 40 years ago?
That's crazy.
(audience applauds)
You're tall.
It's these shoes.
Oh my gosh, these shoes,
I had to actually practice walking in these
'cause I was just like... (laughs)
Here, I'll just...
(audience laughs and applauds)
I love the socks, I really do.
Yeah, this is my socks.
There we go, now we're the exact same height.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
40 years
and it is just an honor to be in this with you.
(audience applauds)
Oh my goodness.
Now, I was so excited to see that the iconic poster
from Steven King's novel to back in the day when we made it,
they're all having an empowered symmetry of likeness,
which I think is so cool.
So do you wanna recreate it with me as we go to break?
I would love to.
All right here we go, ready?
Let's do it, okay.
(audience applauds)
(gentle music begins)